hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in on you i'm just
checking in to see how your week's going
to help it's going great
hope you're getting out there you're
doing your thing
um i don't know what's going on in the
world and you know what it feels [ __ ]
great i was just sitting here thinking
like jesus christ
oh freckles got a half hour to figure
fill up i really didn't do [ __ ] this
week
i'm studying for this instrument [ __ ]
rating
i got my flash cards it's like
70 pages of information plus links
to more information in the dreaded fair
aim book and all of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i'm just walking it down walking it
down i got the first 10 pages down i'm
just [ __ ]
walking it down there's all these
[ __ ] acronyms
and all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] and um
i'm just trying to get into
the fun of actually learning all of this
stuff
you know you know
[ __ ] so anyway i was thinking like
well i haven't really done anything i
haven't played drums i haven't done
[ __ ] [ __ ] i
i haven't even gone for a drive i've
just been studying this [ __ ] and getting
on my little home
simulator
um and uh
i was thinking like well maybe i could
just talk about something that's in the
news and i realized that i have no
[ __ ] idea what's going on in the news
you know and when i was growing up
i was always told you should watch the
news you should know what's going on out
there
she know what's going on out there what
they left out is the fact that you feel
hopeless to change any of it
and it's going to be all bad news you
can't [ __ ] change it
and it's going to leave you with this
depressing like helpless
feeling so what is the [ __ ] point oh
jesus bill you gonna go this dark this
early i'm sorry hey you know what do you
want from me
so i just sort of tapped out you know
i'm trying to live this nice little
simple life i study for my little test
you know drop my kid off at school i
pick her up
we go to the park we go to the driveway
we ride our bikes we play these games
and uh that's it
that's it that's all i do she was
actually
at the park and uh
she went over to the you know the little
playground area
she had a little mask on and [ __ ] you
know
this boy came up to her and said hey you
you want to be my friend
she just goes yeah and then they just
started playing it was the cutest thing
ever
and finally the little boy's little
sister came over
and the boy goes this is my new friend
and then my daughter blurted out my name
is so and so
uh i'm a
i'm a big kid and i have a baby named
and she named she meant a baby brother
name so-and-so the kid goes how old are
you and she goes i'm four
and the kid goes i'm five and my
daughter goes
can you drive a car
i guess in her head when she turns five
she's gonna be big enough to drive a car
and um i think it's because she's been
gradually just
working her way up the vehicle thing
at such a rapid pla pace you know she
had a tricycle she had a big wheel
and she had a balance bike now she has a
bicycle
and i think like you know she had a
scooter too you know once she got on the
bicycle
like she still messes with the scooter
because you know the scooters
can you can get sort of the same speed
but like just the level of freedom and
how awesome a bicycle is to a little kid
um it's my favorite thing in the world
to watch her go into the garage
and it's all her now she just goes up a
little foot she puts up the kickstand
she gets on it she pushes off and she
rides away
and uh i don't know
i also like listening to her talk to her
just how what her identity was
that she was a big kid she's a big
sister
you know
and when in a year from now when she
turns five she's gonna drive a car
i thought that was pretty i said all
right you know she feels she's feeling
pretty good about herself
um so you get to feel that feeling then
it's like why would i
[ __ ] that up and then sit down and turn
on the news
you know
i'm content to be ignorant i think that
that's what it is
i'm content oh you know what i did see
some news
some big news that i'm actually going to
look up now is
aaron rodgers
allegedly said that he is done in green
bay
which um
i can't believe that it got to that
place
um sucks when that happens
so um let me see what we got here
aaron rodgers packers standoff what's
behind it how they
make amends for aaron rodgers and a new
breed of superstar a dream job is no
longer enough
oh jesus washington post going in
packers have begun
looking at other quarterbacks with the
aaron rodgers situation
um
yeah man i mean that's a [ __ ]
that's an insane insane situation
how it ends up getting to that you know
that [ __ ] person's saying for a new
breed a superstar
i know what they're saying i'll buy that
in like the nba and stuff like that but
if you're gonna go out there
and do what a pro football player does
which is essentially take years off of
their life
um i think you have to go for it on
fourth down
i mean i think that's a simple ask isn't
it
there must be just like a level of
dysfunction
i mean how can they not be i don't even
get how that [ __ ] team works it's
like the fans own the team
when i look at the green bay packers it
reminds me of when i went to
finland and they tried to tell me that
they had no rich people in their country
and i said oh really they said yeah this
is a socialist thing we all do you know
blah blah blah blah and i said all right
um and by the way for all you [ __ ]
people over here who've allowed that
word socialist to like be demonized like
i don't know what people think i don't
know what people even think that that
means anymore it was a beautiful country
beautiful people the whole thing was
working and doing all of that but like
uh they said there was no rich people in
the country and i was just like well
do you have banks you have bankers and
they're like yeah and then i just
laughed at them
it's like somebody is going to cheat
somebody is always going to [ __ ] do
that somebody's always going to try to
[ __ ] cut the corners but um
i don't know you know it'd be great what
if i actually just looked up
socialism finally found out what that
word meant beyond this whole [ __ ]
um let me see here
the whole i don't know what what we've
turned it into
i think so socialism in in my country if
you're not in my country what it's it
starts
what it means now is i i think if you
want something for your tax dollar and
you want to call out corporations
in a certain way uh they just
brand you like if you say you know hey
we should [ __ ] you know all this
money was spending on wars what if we
spent it on some health care
you [ __ ] socialist
socialist i i want something for my
money
instead of just watching it go into
[ __ ] corporations who are profiting
off this never-ending [ __ ]
you [ __ ] pieces why did you get the
[ __ ] out of the country
all right a political and economic
theory
i love that theory because yeah they're
all theory capitalism is a theory
they're all theories in theory this is
how it should work but in reality this
is how it works
all right of social organization which
advocates
that the means of production
distribution exchange should be owned or
regulated by a community as a whole
well that's never going to work
look at us in this pandemic trying to
just trying to get maybe
you know 50 percent of people
are pulling in the same direction you
can't do it
i think uh i would say that that doesn't
work
because well none of them work
because people are running them we are
inherently flawed
and uh yeah i really just think the
people that are drawn to it
i don't know to running [ __ ] be it your
local [ __ ]
chapter of something or other this
there's a [ __ ]
i know it's very hard to get the right
person in there someone who actually
gives a [ __ ] and doesn't have a [ __ ]
ego that's a very
difficult thing to find but anyway um
you know capitalism that that works on
the theory that hey everybody has a
chance and everybody
you know you pull yourself up by your
bootstraps and you tried it
you know and then you [ __ ] see the
end result of like 150 years of that and
like like
like two percent of the people own
eighty percent of the wealth
it's just like you know when you got ten
[ __ ] cities and all of this [ __ ] so i
don't know
i have no idea but um
i don't even know finland's is is
finland socialist now that i opened my
big goddamn mouth
i can tell you what it is [ __ ]
beautiful
is socialist or capitalist
uh finland has a capitalist economy why
finns are so much wait wait wait wait
opinion finland is a capitalist paradise
finland is not a capitalist paradise
what the [ __ ]
uh finland has a capitalist economy why
are the finns
so much happier than us
oh god is it can you can you [ __ ]
google anything that isn't click bait
anymore
like what page do you have to go to
how the [ __ ] would you know it go to a
country and know if somebody's happier
i remember oprah did some dumb segment
on that the happiest places on earth
god bless her but why i was just sitting
there looking at going like
you know that's one of those things
where they're like they go dubai
dubai is this amazing place it's built
on [ __ ] slave labor
aren't they all though in some way i
don't [ __ ] know jesus christ
sorry i just been studying i haven't
been doing anything
and i haven't been watching the news you
know what i i did do is i watched uh
i watched the paid uh the patriots i
watched the bruins
versus the devils the other night um we
ended up losing but it was a great game
and uh there was some
[ __ ] sick ass goals
just i'll tell you man i respect the
devils man they got some [ __ ] snipers
um there was one almost goal that would
have been one of the goals of the year
one of our defensemen just laid down on
the ice and the [ __ ] dude
was stick handling jumped over him
landed
continued to stick handle but couldn't
quite tuck it home
i was just like i was on the phone with
somebody
because my [ __ ] job never ends
it was hilarious and i was sitting there
talking to him
i was going yeah so you know i figured i
could start my tour if people get the
vaccination and
meanwhile the planes happen uh the play
is happening i'm like you know get it
back and i just go
[ __ ] he goes what what
i was like i'm sorry this guy in the
devil's jumped over abroad
it's like all right you just [ __ ]
freaked me out so um
we got the islanders i think we got the
islanders tonight
playing them back to back and ever since
we got taylor hall we've just become a
different team
it's given us two legit lines um
we got a new goaltender i don't know
what his name is because i just been
studying he's been playing great
and um it's exciting
celtics is i kind of just you know
win some lose some and meanwhile the
[ __ ] new york knicks are on a tear
they are just on a tear they're a fourth
seed
i think they have finally turned it
around there and
and meanwhile everybody's talking about
the brooklyn nets and then the
philadelphia 76ers have a better record
um but does that help them
i don't think so because i feel like the
nba told us with the all-star game who's
gonna make the finals
or is it the final i always forget is it
the stanley cup finals in the nba final
or the other way around
let me get this down for one and be a
finals with an s
stan lee cup
and that also says finals one of them is
only a final
and one of them is a finals wiki has it
as the finals
plural
and be a
final wiki let's see here
and and wikipedia has it down as the nba
finals
because whenever i say finals people go
bill it's final
there isn't more than one finals
those are the same people who go why do
you call it football
they think like they've come up with
some sort of george carlin analogy
it's like because it i think i believe
it started with some sort of hybrid of
soccer
in uh rugby and the name stuck
i think that that's why is that why do
you have a king and a queen
and then also have like political uh a
prime minister
you know i don't give a [ __ ] you know
why are you guys fat uh because we eat
too much our food supplies poison do you
have any money you have any [ __ ] nice
questions about america
why is it so big and beautiful like a
genocide and slavery
um sorry anyway uh flowing ahead
i did uh i did a couple of shows last
night
i did a couple of shows
and uh hey the weirdest experience last
week
i did stand up at this church this
methodist church
which is uh i believe catholicism
without the pedophilia as far as i can
tell
um but then and then i went over to the
comedy store i did my first spot at the
store in forever
since the beginning of this pandemic and
i had two of the [ __ ] best sets
i've had during all of this [ __ ]
and i didn't tape i just went up there i
just emptied my [ __ ] brain
and i was like wow i feel like i got a
new 10 minutes and i have been chasing
that
my last like three sets and it just was
like
i was just eating it every [ __ ] where
i went i wasn't eating it it just wasn't
going well
i felt like i was just stuck in the mud
i couldn't pull out right that's what
she said
um oh i think that's what he said that
would be that's what he said i couldn't
pull out
i was trying i love those jokes by the
way that's what she said
and that's what he said always funny to
me i don't care if they're old corny
jokes
um or inappropriate at the workplace i
don't care i like them
i stand by them you know it's funny i
was thinking about this whole [ __ ]
cancel culture thing and you know what
the reality is
is nothing uh
you really can't cancel somebody like
unless you get the cops involved and
they actually get arrested
and they go to jail you know but as far
as like this whole [ __ ] that you've
been cancelled
i've noticed with with comedians at
least is they post
shows and the shows still sell out
and then what happens is the people that
said they were canceled when they
realized that they're
not canceled is they then
bully and attack the promoter
of the show to try to get the show
canceled
um that's what really happens
so that is one of those things that i
just kind of hope
goes away when we when
whenever we come back that that goes
away because that [ __ ] it really just
expanded beyond
these abusive monsters that were that
were out there and needed to be dealt
with it just sort of then expanded
into i don't like your thought process
therefore we've decided your career and
your dream is over it's just like wait
what what happened when did when did it
expand into this
talk to me about your politics i don't
like those yeah
it's a great big [ __ ] weird thing out
there which is why i'm trying to make my
life a little more simple
uh all right one more cute story with my
daughter
i was driving home from school she goes
dad do you love me and i said yeah and
she goes how much
i'm like this much i just realized i
took my hands off the wheel of the car
like if i loved her i would have
i don't know what i wiggled my ears
and i said to her do you love me and she
goes yes and i said why
she goes because you make me waffles and
pancakes
i don't know why they don't have little
kids they should have four-year-old kids
um write hallmark cards
because they just get right to it
you know i'm [ __ ] sitting there
trying to buy my wife
a mother's day card which i did i bought
my mom one two you know i bought all the
mom my mother-in-law everybody right
and uh it's so weird to go in there and
buy a mass-produced card
you know that says all of these things
and the i
i just what blows my mind is how much
women love these cards and it's like
don't you realize that there's another
woman right now
reading those exacts this thousands of
women
reading those exact words
those exact [ __ ] words
you know so how sincere is this
shouldn't i be buying a blank card
and writing how i feel that's what i i
usually do that
not because i'm open emotionally jesus
we know it's not that i usually do that
because by the time i go ah
[ __ ] i gotta get a card i show up
and it looks like after you know the
card section of whatever
you know the mother's day card or what a
valentine's day card
that section at that point looks like
there was a parade and i just missed it
you know there's envelopes on paper on
the floor and [ __ ]
so then i just buy the blank one and um
i think what i'm going to do now is i'm
just going to start
plagiarizing the cute things my daughter
says to me and then just write that to
my i might write that
to my wife happy mother's day i love you
because you make me waffles and pancakes
i mean how much better is how much
i mean that has everything you need to
know in life
you know i love you because you're
showing me love
and you can do it in the most simple way
and i feel it to the core of my soul
all of that is in there you don't have
to have this fancy script
i love you because you make me waffles
and pancakes i mean that is just air you
can't [ __ ] with that
that is just air tight
that right there is better than any of
the [ __ ] [ __ ] i was reading in that
cvs
um oh god and then standing there
waiting for the woman stalking the
shelves to come back over to the
register
because those [ __ ] drugstores won't
hire enough [ __ ] people
poor woman standing on there with her
back to me and she's [ __ ] putting
razor blades and [ __ ] on the goddamn
shelf yeah yeah you ready you're about
ready
and i'm like yeah i'm ready i'm i'm over
here trying not to get upset at you
try not to be selfish because i want to
get on with my [ __ ] day
you about ready
all of that [ __ ] all of those [ __ ]
stores man
jesus christ they skeleton crew
don't even tell me it's because of the
pandemic they've been doing that since
[ __ ] before
the [ __ ] poor person at the goddamn
register or the cvs
also has to run over to make sure the
geriatric people who the only people who
eat that [ __ ] ice cream
you know they run over there what do you
want you want rocky road they have all
those old
school [ __ ] flavors
chocolate strawberry vanilla rocky road
aunt mabel what would you like all right
let's do a little bit of advertising
here
let's do some ad reads
babel oh jesus that's a perfect name for
this [ __ ] podcast
uh babel uh for most of us learning a
second language
in high school or college wasn't exactly
a high point in our academic careers
jesus christ talk about what class you
took
and what if any do you remember etc yeah
i took french and i failed miserably
i got all the way up to french 2a
because i wasn't smart enough to be on
full
french too and then um
i don't know it's a long story i went
back to french one to get the basics and
go back and i still [ __ ]
i still bumped it and um i don't know
i keep starting and stopping and failing
can you help me babel
now thanks to babel the number one
selling language learning app there's an
active
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you're all
you'll be traveling abroad connecting in
a deeper way with your family
or you just have some free time what do
you mean connecting in a deeper way with
my family are you suggesting that you
can't connect
with english in a deep way i love you
because you make me waffles and pancakes
or is it because you're experiencing the
wonderment of learning a new language
with your family i think that that's
what that i think that
that's what it is or you just have some
free time babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons that you actually use
in the real world
talk about what language you will you
choose
oh i'm going to try french for the 15
millionth time
sorry for the uh uh um what's it owns
twos threes coutures const
cons million million [ __ ] time
uh babel's 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go
where do you take your babble lessons
well i would do it in the car when i'm
sitting in traffic so i don't feel like
i'm wasting time
babel designs their courses with
practical real world conversation in
mind things you get to use in everyday
life this is the way you do it people
15 minutes right as your brain starts to
get tired babel's like hey man
au
whatever the [ __ ] you say say fee that
means uh it's
it's girl other language learning apps
use
ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts oh so this isn't just
some algorithm
their teaching method method has been
significantly proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different language including spanish
french italian and german
um plus babble speech
recognition technology helps you to
improve your pronunciation and accent
uh start your new language learning
journey today with battle i'm gonna do
this [ __ ] after i get my [ __ ]
instrument
ready right now when you're you purchase
a three-month babble subscription
you'll get an additional three months
for free that's six months for
the price of three just go to babel.com
and use the promo code burr b-u-r-r
that's babel
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code burr
with an extra three months for free
babel language for life
ah look who it is helix everybody helix
helix sleep has a quiz that just takes
two minutes to complete
man and it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from
sorry they have soft medium and firm
mattresses
mattress is great for cooling down if
you sleep hot gross
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size folks
um if you've been awesome it's been
awesome getting messages from so many of
you
who have also found the helix mattress
of your dream so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz
um you order the mattress that's you
that's your match to
and the mattress comes right to your
your door shipped for free
you don't even need to go to a mattress
store again and by the way is there
anything more important than a [ __ ]
good night's sleep for your overall
health they're doing all of these
studies now that show how
how much it fights potential uh
cognitive issues when you get older um
to not be walking around with the tired
brain which i've done for the last 30
years which is why i'm such a [ __ ]
so get yourself a good mattress helix is
awesome but you don't need to take my
word for it helix was awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2020
by in
and by gq and wired magazine uh just go
to helixsleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up gross
uh for you if you don't love it but you
will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
oh look who it is the last one everybody
it's all zip
do you think aaron rodgers put his name
up on zip recruiter for [ __ ]
teams around the nfl uh recent data
shows that
out of all the female owned businesses
it is estimated that one in three
is owned by a mom
what one in three businesses
wait recent data shows that all of the
female owned oh i thought they were
saying all the businesses one in three
is owned by a mom i was like
what the [ __ ] are these feminists
complaining about
if one in three businesses are owned by
a mom how many other ones are just owned
by a woman who doesn't have any kids yet
now i gotta sit here and listen to this
[ __ ] sorry uh ever wonder how
these amazing moms and dads find time to
hire for their businesses while juggling
their families
with zip
that's how they do it and right now you
can try it for free
only at ziprecruiter.com ceo and founder
talia goldstein is one such
mompreneur
entrepreneur mompreneur okay i get it
besides being a mom of two
her personalized matchmaking company
three-day rule is constantly growing and
she needs to hire several matchmakers a
month
so she uses zip
zip recruiters powerful technology helps
her find people with the right
experience and actively invites them to
apply
but talia's not the only employer who
loves it
recruiter man four out of five employees
who post on ziprecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day and right
now
you can try ziprecruiter for free at
this address
uh ziprecruiter.com burr this special
offer is only good at
zip
recruiter.com spell it out geez it says
oh spell out burr b-u-r-r by the way
they want to spell out recruiter that's
not an easy one r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r
dot com aaron rodgers should put his
name on zip recruiter
they actually do don't they have that on
nfl waivers isn't that their zip
recruiter
i love that how do these women you know
who run their own businesses
juggle a family uh it's called
babysitters
you outsource that's how you do it
they're not sitting there down at a
[ __ ] construction site holding a baby
you know everybody knows everybody knows
how you juggle a family and own a
business
you miss your children growing up
that's how you do it jesus christ how
many times people are going to ask that
[ __ ] question it's one of the easiest
answers
in the world in the world world world
all right
that's the um that's the podcast here
everybody uh
i hope you uh enjoyed it i know i was a
little
all over the place today but uh
i don't know i'm gonna be seeing
cross-eyed here i don't know when i'm
taking this [ __ ] test but uh i gotta
cram this 70 pages of [ __ ]
information into my goddamn head
um
yeah that's what i have to do and i got
a lesson today so that's what i'm doing
bruins versus islanders tonight
hopefully i'll have a little bit of time
to watch that
and uh that's it be nice to each other
everybody
stop watching the [ __ ] news just be
nice to each other you know
don't buy holiday cards have your
four-year-old just say something cute to
you and you just write down that you
plagiarize
your own toddler by a young child right
is that what i say
i don't know people i'm trying to wrap
it up here all right that's it enjoying
the music
if you knew this podcast after the music
there'll be an additional bonus
uh episode of not a bonus episode a a
greatest hits episode of thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast coming from a thursday
afternoon just before friday morning
when you have podcast
from a year ago 10 years ago i don't
know how andrew does
but that's what's coming up next all
right have a great weekend you [ __ ]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast
for monday may the 6th
may the 6th did you read did you read
your forecast for the day
huh what does it say what is that [ __ ]
called astrology
why don't we look up old [ __ ]
astrology right now
you know what it's raining out here in
los angeles everybody always freaks out
oh my god it's raining i can't drive in
this stuff
um oh here's astrology and who we have
on here star
of the day who will it be george clooney
evidently he's a taurus and he was born
today
may 6 1961. happy birthday to george
clooney who turns
52 today um
what kind of an [ __ ] i'll tell you
what kind of an [ __ ] looks this [ __ ]
up adolf hitler
and thank god he did maybe if he didn't
have his head up in the stars
he might have won that [ __ ] war right
and i'll tell you right now most of us
wouldn't be here including myself
do you think that beady little
shark-eyed [ __ ]
amy schumer cheeked psycho would [ __ ]
put up with my redheaded face walking
around i don't think he would
i don't think he would i think he'd look
at me and go nah
oh [ __ ] um i drank like a [ __ ] idiot
late yesterday
i was going so well everybody when i was
fighting that demon
that little [ __ ] that little harlot
that i like to call
alcoholism i was doing so great and by
great what i meant was i was actually
working out in the morning before i went
out and got shit-faced
that's how i [ __ ] wrestle that demon
to the ground huh you like that [ __ ]
huh empty calories look good you have to
kill her
tap out dude tap out um now i've been
doing great i've been doing the stairs
this is set of stairs down the [ __ ]
street
and i know what most people see most
people drive by they see a set of stairs
but not all freckleface here you know
what i see i see a free gym
so i've been going up and down these
[ __ ] things
all right well there's there's four
sets of stairs and i'm doing them with
uh cleveland's own jason lawhead
all right there's four sets of stairs so
we're looking at it like a basketball
game all right the first set of stairs
is the first quarter second stairs
second quarter you get the idea
right something to take our mind off the
fact that we're a couple of booze hounds
trying to drag our [ __ ] drunk asses
hungover asses up these stairs see
basically
you go up down up that's the first
quarter then the second quarter is a
short one
so that one you gotta run you're trying
to run him out of the building
or if you walk it that means uh you know
you blew a [ __ ] eight point lead
right up down up
and then we [ __ ] uh the last two
uh brutal up down up and then up down up
and then you walk all the way around you
loop around and then you got the last
two and you go up down up
up down up and that's [ __ ] overtime
and you basically want to kill yourself
afterwards but i got to tell you
something
you know if you do that [ __ ] and you
come home
and you resist the urge to get a
breakfast burrito
or whatever the [ __ ] it is you do in
your neck of the woods if you just have
a f
if you just sit there and you force
yourself to eat like you're in a prison
camp
the weight will come off um
why am i talking about this [ __ ] yeah
i'm back to having my banana for
breakfast
although if i do that [ __ ] workout i
do uh
i'll have the oatmeal and the banana
that's what i do if you guys are ever
wondering what my beauty secrets are
if you ever wondered how it is that i
keep the glow how i keep the light in my
eye
how when i walk into a room everybody
just goes wow who is that gentleman
and what are his ideas that i can invest
in um
that's what it is right there up down up
on the [ __ ] stairs
a bowl of oatmeal with nothing else in
it maybe a couple of bananas
slices of banana and that's it you eat
like you're in some bamboo cage
treading water with a couple of rats all
right
that's what you have to do in your
[ __ ] 40s
if you don't want to end up with one of
those sammy hagar torsos
you know were you still trying to wear
the t-shirt
and you look okay straight on as long as
it's black but when you turn to the side
you just got all that extra [ __ ] meat
you know
you ought to be able to put your hand
down and be able to get your thumb to
the back and your fingers
to the front all right when your whole
hand could just be on the side you got
you got to shave down that ham
all right so anyways that's what i'm
trying to do i'm trying to shave it down
i was at my fighting [ __ ] weight like
an [ __ ] they put on like 13 pounds
being a [ __ ]
goddamn waffle eating [ __ ] [ __ ]
so now look what i have to do i gotta
eat like a [ __ ]
guy like i'm in uh a goddamn uh p.o.w
camp why do i do that to myself
how many [ __ ] times bill are you
gonna get down to your weight be like
oh that's great you know what in
celebration i'm gonna have a
cheeseburger and some ice cream and go
right back to the tub of [ __ ] [ __ ] i
was before i'm sick of it
i hate myself i'm sick of the cycle um
whatever so it's raining out here which
is great
because the hills are on fire the hills
are on fire out here which
are actually a phenomenal part of nature
out here
um if human beings weren't living in the
hills
it would be great we could all just sit
back and sort of enjoy nature doing what
it does
the hills catch on fire i've gone
through this before right basically this
is how the weather works out here
um it rains you used to be january and
february now it like [ __ ] rains in
december it's like earlier you know
and [ __ ] all you people in minnesota
okay with your oh my god it's snowing in
may
why are you acting like you didn't just
put away your mittens
okay you live in minnesota
you know what you signed up for what do
you think you're gonna be doing in may
skiing oh it would have been nice um
46 [ __ ] inches and everybody's out
there acting like you know
they're acting like it's snowing in may
i wish i could have put on fox news i
know they were like
global warming huh um
[ __ ] the polar ice caps melting it's
snowing
in minnesota in may
let's see what the liberals have to say
about this is that a polar bear
um so anyways the [ __ ] hills were on
fire we
we drove we drove out to uh we drove me
and la had did uh chumash casino
somebody told me chumash means number
five
in uh native american i have no idea i
don't know if it's the name of their
tribe
you know they stood on the hills out
here when they were on fire and yelled
at the apaches
you know jew mash [ __ ] i don't
know if they said that i have no idea
well if they just put five fingers in
the air and that meant to gather up
gather up we're gonna go get some [ __ ]
[ __ ] tonight i have no idea what it
meant but all i know is i went out there
and i had a great [ __ ] time
but we're driving out there and i know
you californians are used to this [ __ ]
but we're just driving out there and all
of a sudden
you just come over the hill on the
highway
and you look in the distance and there's
an entire hill that is just completely
and
can't say completely engulfed in plain
flames it's just walls of fire
working its way up the hill
and um you just sort of drive by it
taking video not paying attention to
where you're going like i did
i'll try and send you some of the video
um
g billy you really going to try how are
you going to try what [ __ ]
select it and hit send
i'm going to send the video i'll have
the video okay
anyways um and i actually went home
the next day and i was watching these
firefighters on the [ __ ] news
if you get a chance go on youtube maybe
there's some clips out there
watching these guys fight the fires it's
it's unbelievable
first of all it's like 85 [ __ ]
degrees out without the hill being on
fire
and like seven of them walk up this hill
here i am bragging about doing these
stairs up down up down these guys have
like a [ __ ]
you know 60 70 pounds worth of equipment
that heavy raincoat and they're just
walking up this hill like it's
nothing they get up there
i notice one guy's got the red helmet
he's leading the way so evidently he's
the [ __ ] chief
so they're standing right next to this
wall of fire and he just kind of yeah
it's so bad at that that nist and then
these [ __ ] guys
they they just get after it two guys
have these giant
[ __ ] chainsaws they start cutting
away the brush the other guys are
grabbing the brush throwing it in the
opposite direction
of the fire next thing you know there's
a trail and they've established a
perimeter
you know and the fire's like wait a
minute what the [ __ ] happened i thought
everything was all good and they said i
don't think so
fire why don't you just sit there and
either go in the other direction over
[ __ ] you already burned out or just
sadly [ __ ] fade away like a child
star
that's exactly what they did i watched
them save people's houses
they're unbelievable and it was in that
moment that i realized i could never be
a firefighter
i don't have what it takes i don't i
have the wrong pigment to be walking up
that [ __ ] hill
with all of that [ __ ] on you know i was
joking that night in the comedy club
that if i worked in a
firehouse i'd be that guy who stay hangs
back and like makes the chili
you know everybody calling me a [ __ ]
some homophobic words you know they
would be yeah
there'll be nothing against gay people
it was just all about making me feel
like a [ __ ] chili-making [ __ ] i'd be
sitting there stirring the pot hey
be careful out there guys i heard it's a
hot one
yeah [ __ ] you you [ __ ] goddamn broad
make me some [ __ ]
tuna fish and i'd sit there with my big
fireman red mustache
little tear in my eye
sitting there all alone tasting my chili
eats paprika
oh god do you guys realize not
one nail has been put into my house
since they
demoed it the other day or whatever
[ __ ] was it six weeks ago we're still
fighting with these insurance cuts
over two grand because i know what
they're thinking it's two grand
this guy eventually is going to get sick
of [ __ ] looking at this mess
and you know what they don't know they
don't know what they're dealing with
here they don't know how stubborn i
am i'm going the opposite direction what
i'm really seeing is all my [ __ ]
that i had in the walk-in closet you
know just strewn about
in this room downstairs and i'm just
looking at all of it going what the [ __ ]
do i need this stuff for
what is that do you know what i came
across the other day
do you remember when those michelin ness
throwback jerseys
were all the [ __ ] rage remember that
i remember the late great patrice
o'neal please download his cd mr p
all the proceeds go to his uh his wife
and his mom
um he i think at one point
his entire wardrobe consisted
of those [ __ ] jerseys you know and we
used to give him [ __ ] when he come in
wearing a [ __ ] wide receiver's
jersey saying he was too big he should
only buy throwback lineman jerseys
um and he used to yeah and then of
course he'd [ __ ] trash the [ __ ] out
of us but whatever so
during that time they had a fran
tarkington throwback jersey
the uh the white one
lsu by the way i don't know who ripped
off who probably the vikings ripped off
lsu considering
uh lsu's been around forever but um
i have a [ __ ] fran tarkinton
throwback jersey and i'm like i forgot i
even had that
and then i remembered why i never wore
it because i got it and i put it on
and i looked like an [ __ ]
i don't know what it was about the
colors i don't know if it was the
numbers
i don't know it was my dumb [ __ ] face
but i literally the second i put it on
i looked like i had a fatal disease and
i was waiting for fran tarkington
to show up next to my hospital bed
that's what i look like
so i never [ __ ] wore it i bought this
[ __ ] thing
you know remember those things they're
like 200 bucks 250 i've never
worn that [ __ ] thing
all right and if you can send me an
email
if you're almost five foot 10 like i am
and roughly weigh about a buck 70 to a
buck 80.
depending on how much you're boozing if
you can send me a [ __ ] email
as to why you're a giant fran tarkinton
fan and all that [ __ ] you leave your
address i'll mail that [ __ ] to you
because you know what i'm done with all
of this [ __ ] i
[ __ ] dropped my computer you [ __ ]
i'm done with all of this [ __ ]
all right i'm not gonna be the guy with
a bunch of [ __ ]
you know that gradually ends up my
garage in plastic tins
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not doing it
i'm getting rid of all of my stuff
all these [ __ ] books i already read
and i still have them i'm getting rid of
all of them
you know what i was actually thinking
this is a this would be a [ __ ]
hilarious
way to in a very sneaky way gradually
get out of a relationship that you want
to be in
you know possibly the biggest you know
[ __ ] way out of relationship rather
than just sitting down
what i've always told you guys to do is
you just sit down with the person you
just say listen
we need to talk you sit down and you
just start it off with i'm not happy
and that's the theme well what if i did
this that knit
i'm just not happy
what is it is it the sex i'm just not
happy whatever man or woman
all right so say you didn't want to have
that that conversation
say just give you so many douche chills
what if
what you did was without her knowing
just ever so
subtly over the course of eight
excruciating months
still in that relationship you didn't
want to be in what if he just gradually
kind of got rid of all of your
[ __ ] you know and the way you cover for
it is you do yoga every day
so you just tell you know your
significant other that it's just this
spiritual
new spiritual path that you're taking
and they'll be psyched in one way
because i was getting rid of all this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] great there's more
room for my stuff right
and then when you're down to like a
backpack
worth of [ __ ] and the clothes on your
back
you put your toothbrush in your little
fanny pack whatever you have left
and you just hey i'm gonna go run some
errands
you just walk out the door and that's it
you're out there's another way to do it
people
you know someday i'm putting the book
out thousand and one ways to get out of
a [ __ ] relationship that's one of
them right there
that's number 872. i just flip through
the book
a little manuscript that's one for you
all right um anyways
how far into this podcast are we
everybody
that was a lovely 16 minutes here how
about
a little advertisements
how the hell do i get to him live reads
yeah okay here we go
pro flowers hey everybody guess what it
is next sunday
you know what is it's mother's day who's
more important than your mom
nobody unless she didn't stick around
you know then i would just wait till
father's day and get the flowers for
your dad
as always he can handle it long as he
won't slap you in the face with him
going what are you giving me flowers for
what are you trying to say about me
you think i'm like that guy that
basketball player
um anyways uh
mother's day is this sunday okay here's
the angle we have this week
pro flowers everybody sibling rivalry
just doesn't end because you moved out
of the house
you can still one-up them your brother
sends a card
your sister remembers to call guess what
you do
you top both of them and send flowers to
your mom on mother's
day it's brilliant all you got to do is
just call up the number
big bang boom you can do it right from
your q from your cubicle
here's the offer pro flowers has 100
blooms for mom for just 19.99 that's 50
percent off everybody
for just ten dollars more and you're
gonna tell me your mom's not worth ten
dollars more you're really gonna sit
there
and look me and my computer screen right
in the face and tell me she's not worth
ten dollars more
ten bucks more you upgrade to a hundred
blooms with premium with a premium pink
vase
and chocolates you just need my code
burr
b-u-r-r when you order to get these
special prices
um 100 blooms for mom is a huge uh
is a huge bouquet or a bouquet whoever
the hell you say it
basically you're doing more than a card
you're going to one-up all your friends
family and everybody else go to
proflowers.com click on the microphone
in the top right hand corner and type in
burr
that's proflowers.com click on the
microphone and type in bur
order mother's day flowers today it's
this sunday
okay stop having it in the back of your
head stop having a string tied around
your finger just do it right now
and relax enjoy the rest of your day
okay
e-voice everybody e-voice is the reason
you're going to make more money in 2013.
hear what i just said you're sitting
around going how am i going to make more
money in 2013
i have your answer e-voice when your
customers call
you'll have your own toll-free number
professional greeting dial by name
directory and more
you'll sound like a fortune 500 company
even if you're living in your mom's
basement
and you know what that does it blows
away your competitors e-voice lets you
give out one number
that rings wherever you are the beach
the bar
doesn't matter you'll sound like you're
at the office
you gotta go to e-voice and use my promo
code bill
evoys takes all your voicemails
transcribes them and sends to you
sends them to you instantly as you text
or email
so not only is this thing phenomenal if
you're in business it's even better
if you're trying to start a business
while you still have another job
okay because the person on the other end
of the line is not going to know that
and if something important happens you
get the text message
you know what you do you go run to the
bathroom excuse me everybody
i had i had indian food last night you
take off and you handle your business
you gradually get your own business
going
all right so here's the deal go to
evoice.com promo code bill that's evoice
dot com
promo code bill or just uh go to the
podcast page on billboard.com
you click on the e-voice banner right
now
that is it god bless you and uh god
bless the united states of america
all right back to the podcast everyone
um
so as always you know what my life is my
life is travel
my life is booze my life is sports
that's it like i was supposed to make
like
like if i was in rehab or some [ __ ] and
i was supposed to make a pie
about what it is that i do you know
and i swear to god no matter what i
wrote i know the person would be like
you know looking at this pie i see a lot
of sadness
it's like dude are you looking at the
pie i travel i tell jokes and then i get
drunk afterwards where do you see the
sadness in there
it's my job to find sadness i'll [ __ ]
you
all right make an addiction your [ __ ]
life's mission
you know i realize i'm gonna i'm gonna
give away some of these books that i
have
and uh i also didn't say uh
i didn't say where to send the emails to
for the fran tarkington jersey
send it to uh uh bill billberg.com
and i'll sift through those
[ __ ] i might even send you a
book with it
huh you want to read about bob probert i
have his hard covered autobiography
um maybe ric flair to be the man you got
to beat the man
i mean what am i supposed to i have read
them i got it it's in the [ __ ] memory
bank
you know what sucks is one time i took a
bunch of used books down the street to
this bookstore
and it brought them in and this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i think i told this story
i bought that anthony keatis one i was
you know jumping on a plane i'm like oh
the guy from red hot chili peppers
the guy's a rock star he never has a
shirt on how much [ __ ] did this guy get
i want to read about it right so i read
his book and it was
that was all right you know
i thought he was kind of a [ __ ] to flee
seemed like a bully
kind of seemed like he had like a
[ __ ] uh
you know that battered wife relationship
with flea
i love you bro i love you and then does
something really mean then uh flea i'm
sorry man i'm so come on back
stop being mean to me anthony right it
just was really uncomfortable in parts
of it
you know and
maybe i was [ __ ] superimposing that i
have no idea what whatever so i bring it
down there
you know do you realize the douchebag
behind the [ __ ] counter
kind of like did some sort of half a
laugh like laughing that i bought this
[ __ ]
book you know what i mean
and it's just like dude what was i
supposed to read the autobiography of
your life
huh the sarcastic guy at the [ __ ]
used bookstore
surrounded by books although your life
wouldn't make a good one the irony of
that how about that
huh oh jesus the violent thoughts that
went through my head i didn't say
anything i was actually embarrassed
which happens to me a lot in life people
just catch me off guard and they call me
out for the pathetic douche that i am
and i believe it or not for as much as i
handle hecklers on stage when i go off
stage
i think that that's uh the microphone's
like my utility belt the second that's
not in my hand
i go back to being the pathetic douche
that needs to go on stage
to feel good about himself wow this is
very therapeutic this week
pubic therapeutic that didn't sound
right
there are pusians um anyways did anybody
watch the uh the celtics
new york knicks series how [ __ ]
amazing was that
all right and i called it the [ __ ]
boston celtics have the most
hot in the goddamn league
all you [ __ ] nick fans who had texted
me when you were up by 20
with like eight minutes to go in the
fourth quarter was hilarious it was
already coming in
all the text messages
hey hey oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] celtics within like went
on a 20-0
run got it down to like four points or
whatever so maybe we were down like 25
i don't even know and um
and i love that we we were down by like
20 points in the fourth quarter
and none of the celtics fans left i'm
sure a couple did but for the most part
the place was still packed
chanting let's go celtics you know
laker fans i'm not saying this in a bad
way but if you want to learn how to be
better fans
that's something you guys ought to do
you know what i mean
now if we were the lakers this year who
had way more talent than the celtics we
would have got swept
you know and one of our best guys would
have [ __ ] deliberately got a second
technical
because he doesn't want to go out there
and feel the shame of being swept
all of that stuff you know laker fans
i'm i'm extending an olive branch to try
and help you guys become better fans
all right and here's the thing if one of
your players
no matter how much you love him walks
off
on the rest of his teammates you blew
him the next [ __ ] game
you don't chant mvp at him thus boosting
his ego even higher
to the point when he gets an injury he
starts tweeting during the game
criticizing his own [ __ ] coach
you know still being a distraction
not even on the team still disrupting
team chemistry
you know what's going to kill me is when
kobe comes back from this injury
um the way that espn [ __ ] drops to
their knees and blows that guy
they are going to talk about this guy
like he did his own surgery
you know they're never gonna think well
they've been working on athletes
with this this same injury and the
advancements in modern medicine are so
[ __ ] incredible
that these guys can sit here with like
you know somebody
dabbing the sweat off their brow as they
have like you know
what do you microscope glasses on or
whatever
to re to [ __ ] re-men kobe bryant so
he can go back out there and probably be
90 of what he used to be as opposed to
back in the day when your career was
over
or like dominique wilkins who had to
take a year off still was comeback
player of the year
they'll never bring that up either
dominique wilkins he won't get any love
he won't get any love about it they'll
act
like nobody has ever done this before
maybe they'll bring up jerry rice coming
back from his uh
acl they'll talk about that maybe
they'll do that and it's gonna it's
gonna make me absolutely
like projectile vomit onto my flat
screen tv
when they're just like i mean what does
it say about this guy
uh his desire to i mean he says it
himself all he wants to
all he wants to do is win as he drives
shaq out of [ __ ] town
drives coaches out of town and vp
walks off the court vp insane all right
i'm done trashing the guy
all right he could blow up both his
achilles and beat up me
and everybody i know while eating a
[ __ ] blt i realized this
all right but if i didn't bring this
[ __ ] up um it wouldn't make me a typical
[ __ ] fan on the internet would it well
there you go
um so anyways all those celtics fans who
were at the game
i just want to tell you out here living
in laker land i couldn't have been more
proud
of the way you guys cheered on the team
and you stuck around
and you didn't [ __ ] run out of the
building you know
nick fans would have stuck around but up
top
up top they would down low all those
other guys
you know all those celebrities
victoria's secret models
sitting next to the [ __ ] action stars
they all would have left spike lee would
have stayed
you know what has he been wearing lately
you know what i mean he looks like
he was a huge justin timberlake fan and
he's also going to clown college
all right anyways have anybody been
watching any of the uh the nhl uh
playoffs
they've been phenomenal so far of course
i'm watching the bruins maple leafs
and uh can anybody explain this to me
because this seems to be
a anytime there's a playoff series
in in uh i would say in basketball and
hockey
to be specific not in baseball because
baseball it's more about your stat and
pitcher
um but the first two games
of the bruins maple leafs series
okay game one it looked like we were
going to sweep
the [ __ ] maple leafs it looked like
why the [ __ ] how the [ __ ] did the maple
leafs
even make the playoffs bruins are flying
up and down the ice they're hitting the
maple leafs maple leafs aren't doing
anything
they look like they're intimidated we
score four goals bing bang boom four to
one
easy [ __ ] victory game two comes
around
it's completely 100 percent the exact
opposite
bruins are on their heels the [ __ ]
maple leafs are pushing us around we're
taking
it and now we look like that frustrating
team that i watched all year that can't
score more than two goals
and um can anybody explain to me what
what the [ __ ] that is
you know what happens happens what
happens in uh
those 48 hours between the games
i just i don't understand so tonight
the bruins and maple leafs are playing
again i got to be honest with you
i have no idea what to expect no idea
what to expect but i can tell you this
phil kessel is a great player but has
one of the
i'd say top 10 most hateable faces
in professional sports right now i don't
know what that look
is on his face i think if you have like
a lot of baby fat on your face it makes
you very hateable
i don't know what it is maybe it's the
helmet
then it mushes his cheeks in and they
kind of stick out over his nose i i
don't know what it is why is my voice
cracking like i'm going through puberty
i have no idea
and i'm also of course paying attention
to the uh
canadians ottawa series i was at a i was
at a cookout yesterday
cinco de mayo so dumb i am last year i
actually what day i said what day is
that
cinco de mayo now for all you other
people who didn't know a lick of spanish
like me
that literally means may 5th
that's the name of the holiday the name
of the holiday is may 5th
or the 5th of may or 5th of may i don't
know how to [ __ ] translate it
um but i missed the [ __ ] game and
that look it looked like an
old school adams division
you know even though it was six to one
total lopsided victory
for uh ottawa i really wish that i
watched the game
and i can guarantee you it's gonna make
no sense
i the canadians are gonna come back just
like the maple leafs i'm predicting in
the next [ __ ] game
and they're gonna totally turn around
and they'll probably win six to one
now they won't because i think ottawa
their their goalie's too [ __ ] good
but uh here's a question i have when are
people gonna wise up to that pk subon
[ __ ]
move where he's backing up acting like
he's going to give you the zone
and then he [ __ ] does a couple of
crossovers
leaves his feet and gives you a shoulder
to the face you know
the ref standing right there oh that's a
clean hit
it's a [ __ ] phenomenal move
phenomenal move i don't know i don't
understand why guys don't see it coming
there's got to be a reason anybody
nothing um all right let's let's let's
read one of these these uh
these [ __ ] things here ah jesus do i
need to buy a new wire or something all
of a sudden it's cutting out in one
headphone
all right to trust or not to trust
um oh before i get into that uh
condolences to that uh the referee
um who wrote that soccer game that high
school soccer game out in colorado one
of the worst things i
stories ever he gave somebody a yellow
card
and the 17 year old kid lost his temper
and turned around and punched the guy in
the face
and i don't know if it was the way he
landed i don't know if he had
pre-existing stuff or this kid just
caught him the right way but the guy
the ref went into a coma for like four
or five days and he passed away
so uh it's just
it's the worst
i don't know i can't say it's a word i
mean so many awful things have happened
in the last [ __ ]
month or so but um
oh jesus christ everybody involved on
either side
i mean i know as much as people are
going to get mad at that kid 17 [ __ ]
years old
um i just can't imagine
you know you got your whole life ahead
of you you're going out to play soccer
and you punch a guy in the face and he
dies and now you're looking at a murder
charge or manslaughter whatever they're
going to charge you
and then another thing he's just some 46
year old guy
family man going out to ref a game
and it it caused you end up dead after
it just
i don't know i don't know why i brought
that up
that really kills the [ __ ] comedy
right this be a good time to read some
advertising
all right here we go let's get into the
letters for this week
um to trust or not to trust
what is the question um hey bill i am a
19 year old guy
and have been dating a girl who is
almost two years older than me
for about two months and known her for
about seven months
all right do you realize how many
numbers are in that let's let's start
over again i'm 19
dating a girl who's 21 for two months
and i've known him for seven months okay
i got it
we're in a long distance relationship oh
geez
and have never met oh come on but we
skype almost every day
to trust or not to trust uh not to trust
sir
you might as well be up in a spaceship
her pussy's on the other side of an
ocean dude all right
and you want you're gonna have to have
some incredible bone structure and
verbal skills to keep that woman
satisfied i can tell you that
if you're gonna try and do this over
skype
all right but i plow forward here i live
in the uk
and she's in america uh i love her to
bits and she
says that she loves me i had an issue
before meeting her
and it really felt like i was exercising
demons when i told her about my issues
she's my first girlfriend plus i've had
issues around women previously
as well as bullying in school and we got
everything out in the open
all right it felt like it had set in
jesus some weeks i suck at reading and
some weeks i really suck at reading
let me regroup here he said it felt like
it had set in stone a relationship that
was secure and trustworthy
given we'd shared a lot of our past such
as her getting sexually abused as a
child
as well as her previous relationship
breakdown or breaking down
during these two months i have felt me
myself gaining self-esteem i never
really had as a child
but yeah there always seems to be a butt
with the emails that you get
uh she recently told me she cheated on
me with somebody she met
in the five months between meeting oh
meeting her and starting to date
sir you haven't been dating you've been
skyping
um she tells me it all happened too
quick and she felt pressured into it
i'm unsure how to move forward and if we
have a future together a long-distance
relationship is based on trust
can't can that be repaired thanks bill
you should do a show in england again
soon
um no sir no no this is uh
beyond over you're sifting through ashes
of basically a relationship a physical
one that never existed
and the more you skype with her the
longer the harder it's going to be for
you
to move on all right you said that you
got some self-esteem
i need you to ramp up your self-esteem
even more and have the self-esteem just
say listen
and do it a nice way just say um
i think you're a great person and i
think if you were here things would be
different but you're not
so um i think it'd be better for both of
us
not [ __ ] better for both of us because
then that could then she'll be like but
i'm okay with
it you guys always got to stick with you
when you're talking about getting out of
relationship
all right
just yeah i mean it's over you cheated
on me
it's already hard enough that we're on
different sides of the sides of an ocean
and all we can do is skype you know the
end of the day
just be like i'm not even mad at you
that you cheated on me i understand it
you know human beings we need a human
connection and this is like i'm [ __ ]
uh
ground controlled to major tom like i'm
[ __ ] orbiting the earth here we can't
we can't have a uh we can't have a
relationship here
all right having said that
let me see your goods just one time put
them up against the screen come on you
filthy [ __ ]
sorry um yeah i would not trust her sir
and i would uh i might even go into
therapy if i was you sounds like you had
a rough uh
go of it with the bullying and that type
of thing to the point that uh
you're so pulled back that you're having
relationships
a non-physical one um over the internet
you gotta get out there sir you gotta
get out you know
join a [ __ ] volleyball league
softball league
uh book of the club book of the club
book of the month league
book club of the month whatever the [ __ ]
i'm trying to say uh
if you're not into sports take a [ __ ]
cooking class just get out there
get out there where the broads are at
you know it's even greater
if you just hey let's go you know oh
you're into reading you're into cooking
it breaks the [ __ ] ice i would do
that
all right that's what i would do i would
not trust her sir
all right you deserve more than that
good luck and god bless the united
states of england
um is this a trap oh billy boy
oh danny boy the lights the lights are
calling you
i love the podcast i hope you give me
some perspective on this issue
i am in my early 30s and i've been
married for five years
my wife and i recently have been having
a sexual resurgence in our relationship
after a big lull caused by the birth of
our two kids
and me putting on some extra weight
that's very honest
uh we are back to [ __ ] as much or
more than we did when we first started
dating
you know that was coming off like really
like uh you were a mature man and then
you went right down to my level
no not the birth of our two kids there's
been a sexual
resurgent and uh you know i put on some
extra weight but uh
dropped a few pounds and went back down
[ __ ] as much as we used
um here's a tip for married men if you
want more sex out of your wife
get your ass to the gym it worked for me
there you go
there you go here's a guy practicing
what i have preached
for the six [ __ ] years that i've been
doing this podcast
by the way next month is the six year
anniversary
of me starting this podcast okay
so i am expecting some um i don't know
what some sort of congratulations i
should have done it yet last year when
it was the five year anniversary
um so this guy's going to the gym that's
right he's getting the pecs going he's
fighting off the man tits
you know he's he's [ __ ] not having
that big uh
former [ __ ] uh rock star goddamn gut
you got to get rid of that [ __ ]
and you'll live longer i read something
one time or overheard in the bar
knowing knowing me that every extra
pound of fat that you have is
is is five miles of capillaries
that your heart has to pump blood
through just saying
extra five pounds 25 more miles of
capillaries
so you can imagine if you're 30 pounds
overweight holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's 100
that's a [ __ ] road trip 150 miles
you got to get it off um that's why you
always see little old ladies and little
old men
you don't see jolly old fat 90 year old
guys you don't
they're gone you know
other than bill russell have you ever
seen like a [ __ ]
70 year old seven footer there's a
reason for that
your heart has to [ __ ] pump all the
way down to the tippy toes
okay also my wife has been open and
willing to do any
manner of depraved sexual [ __ ] that i
can think of
jesus dude he goes i am living the dream
i feel like i won the wife lottery well
i would say you do if she's a great
mother too that's phenomenal
so you go see here's the issue oh okay
i'm gonna guess that she wants to bring
somebody else into the bedroom
i'm gonna guess that you [ __ ] open
pandora's box
and the way this is red if it's another
woman you don't give a [ __ ] i'm guessing
she wants another dude that's what i'm
guessing
she wants a little rotisserie action
there little boston market
um
here we go so here's the issue
she has recently been saying that she
thinks it would be really hot
if i [ __ ] another woman in front of
her
oh oh that went
an entirely different direction
she is clear that she doesn't want to
threesome
she doesn't want to participate she just
wants to be there
apparently this is a fairly common
fetish
known as being
a cut queen did you spell it right
c-u-c-k queen
a cuck queen all right people this is
the first word i've learned
the definition to since uh
what is it buggering of being above
getting buggered
anyways he says now i'm a guy now i'm a
guy so obviously
i'm into variety and the idea is
intriguing
and like i said she's willing to do
basically anything i want to do in the
bedroom
so it seems only fair that i would do
what i can to fulfill her sexual
fantasies
still this seems like a bad idea to me
exactly
great instinct sir i don't know what a
reaction is going to be
i don't want to jeopardize my marriage
for something like this
what do you think bill should i just go
for it or listen to the voice in my head
that says this is a bad idea
if i go for it how would you suggest
actually finding women
a woman who was open to the idea of
being [ __ ] in front of my wife
thanks all right here we go
sir you're 100 right you can't [ __ ]
do this and
all the married guys out there who are
like dude what are you out of your
[ __ ] mind i do that in a [ __ ]
second
[ __ ] second i know this chick at the
office not only she [ __ ] banged me in
front of the whole [ __ ] office
hey love of my life look at me homie
i'm [ __ ] begging right all of those
guys
those mouth-breathing morons you know
who piss on the side of the road when
there's a wendy's with the [ __ ]
public bathroom right there all of those
guys don't listen to them
sir you're 100 right some [ __ ] should
just remain a fantasy
okay um
your parents okay you have kids okay and
when that happens
there's a certain level of uh maturity
that you have to [ __ ] have
okay you can't be walking around in the
goddamn [ __ ] outfit
when at any second your [ __ ] kids can
open the [ __ ] door
to your bedroom you know what i'm saying
and it's just gonna be uh
and you're also introducing the chance
of you catching a [ __ ] venereal
disease
okay because first of all any woman
that's going to allow you to do that
is going to be a freak on some [ __ ]
level and evidently
wearing a condom you can still get
herpes
i don't know how it [ __ ] parrot
troops down on your ball bag
i have no idea but evidently you can all
right and i got to tell you
some [ __ ] things some doors should
just remain
closed um
i don't know how i would try to make up
in that area i was gonna say if she
wanted to [ __ ] another dude then you
could just act like you were another
dude and say a bunch of different dudes
[ __ ] to her while you had her bent over
and she's not looking at you so she
could feel you know
you don't maybe wear a different cologne
but this whole uh you know
why don't you just get a blowup doll and
[ __ ] that in front of her huh you like
that that sound of the [ __ ]
you like that [ __ ] oh yeah take it you
poor right maybe you could do that i
don't know what to tell you dude but
i'll tell you right now your instinct to
not do it is 100
correct all right you did hit the
lottery with this woman and there's
another deal dude
you could be gradually opening this [ __ ]
up
you know women are phenomenal masters of
manipulation
okay this might be her roundabout way
of saying i want to [ __ ] another guy
okay
and what she's gonna do is get you dirty
first
right just like politics we can't have
this guy getting to the oval office
unless we got something on him
she's doing she might be doing that same
thing now this is just conspiracy theory
don't look sideways at your wife as
you're eating a bowl of [ __ ] corn
checks
i'm just throwing this [ __ ] out here all
right this might be her roundabout way
of [ __ ] getting her
to be able to have a [ __ ] all right
you get to [ __ ] one
all right and not only does she gotta
[ __ ] gonna [ __ ] him
you gotta sit there and watch it
you know don't
do it do not introduce
other [ __ ] people into your
relationship all right your relationship
when it comes to sex if it's gonna
[ __ ] work
has to be a secret society
as far as my [ __ ] skills go my skill
set
you know i show up to the gym people
know what i do
i got one mid-range jumper that's all
i'm taking everybody knows if you can
stop it you can stop it that's what the
[ __ ] i'm coming with
all right i don't even know how the [ __ ]
i went into that analogy
i was supposed to be making fun of me in
the [ __ ] bedroom i have my little bag
of tricks
that's all i got um
yeah okay now here's something because
i've never done [ __ ] like that
i never went into that area of [ __ ]
freak week
i never did that all right um
and i think if you are in a [ __ ]
healthy relationship
at some point both men and women do want
a variety
and at some point it's going to come up
and you are going to talk about it
and be like you know maybe we went to
vegas maybe yeah
and then in the end you know usually
after you've banged
and got that urge out of your system you
lay there and you just look at each
other yeah what the [ __ ]
we think we can't do that it's [ __ ]
gross we can't do we like that we're
told no it's not
i'm not trying to judge people who do
[ __ ] like that but it would totally
it your you know it is it's a house of
cards and you're pulling one out way
down near the foundation
it might stay up but the whole thing
might come down and you got some kids in
there
so let me ask you this
at the risk of turning this podcast
into uh a complete freak show
not freak show just i don't know because
i really don't judge people what the
[ __ ] they do
um is there anybody out there that is
married has a couple of kids and
uh has has had this scenario
you know has your wife been cool with it
did you just bring some girl
in and you [ __ ] banged her
you know well what exactly what is the
etiquette when you bang another woman in
front of your wife
you know is she just sitting there
watching you know
like she's watching a chess match are
you allowed to throw us some looks like
uh
see that you like that move there
sweetheart
i don't know i don't know what the deal
is i imagine that there's a bunch of
rules
you're not allowed to do it missionary
style if you come you have to look at me
don't look at her i mean that that scene
like there's all these
like you know what it is it's like
you're starting a new sport
it's kind of like mma when it first
started out and you could punch up or
cut somebody in the balls and gouge the
right you could do whatever the [ __ ] you
wanted
and then they'd be like all right we
need some parameters here
dana white came in and said hey no more
[ __ ] uppercuts to the undercarriage
no more eye gouging no kicking in the
face when the guy's on the ground
no punches to the back of the head he
made it civilized
so i imagine that there has to be some
sort of
um you know civility
to the [ __ ] another woman in front of
you
in front of your wife um
look who's kidding who that would be
absolutely phenomenal
but uh i i just i just couldn't imagine
you know my woman
afterwards afterwards and the woman
leaves
and then i take a shower right and then
we're sitting down
you know eating spaghettios
like i would so be praying
that she started the conversation
if that she was going like yeah i
thought that was just wow i thought that
was really
that was really neato
but the absolute [ __ ] worst is if
there would just be complete awkward
silence
and then all of a sudden she starts
tearing up
right and now here you are going buddy
honey you told me to do
it and the [ __ ] kids are sitting
there
i just didn't think you know i know it
was my idea
but i just didn't think that you were
going to enjoy it that much
you know you don't come that fast with
me the [ __ ] kid sitting there
looking like that kid in the shining you
know when he's [ __ ] looking up with
that red rum face
and i'll tell you right now that would
be
a classic [ __ ] 180 that could
possibly happen
because of uh
the delicacy of women's emotions
and i don't mean that like they're
weaker or whatever there's more tapped
into him
or whatever and like i said this also
could be
some [ __ ] top
shelf pimp [ __ ] that she's doing where
she really wants to go [ __ ] another guy
and she knows well the male ego i can't
come at him with this
you know and if her mindset is like hey
it's just sex she's trying to get you on
the same table
page she has to get you [ __ ] she's
got to get you dirty first so
um i don't know but like i said if
there's people out there who've done
this [ __ ]
please email me because i'd love to i'd
love to know
um give me a quick
scenario of what happened and then give
me a long
detailed it's not the act
i get it the picture's been painted i
want to know the aftermath
i want to know afterwards like what the
f how to [ __ ]
i want to know what was the first topic
that was discussed
other than the fact that your wife had
an outer body experience
of as far as like the whole intercourse
with you
you know and what is she doing
is she saving this up to think about
later or is she literally engaging from
across the [ __ ] room
you know basically doing the sexual
version
of the guy who goes to the game with his
face painted
oh [ __ ] great email by the way sir
great [ __ ] email look at us christ
we're all the way up to 55 [ __ ]
minutes here
um all right let's let's let's shower
off with some more
some more advertising here actually i
think i got all of them this week didn't
i
is that it i think i have one more at
the end of the podcast i have to read
um let me make sure because i get in
trouble each week you didn't read
zippy.net what the [ __ ] did you miss
that
what do we got here
oh oh that's right that's right see this
i checked i did my [ __ ] homework
um we do have another read if i can find
it
where oh where is that other damn read
legalzoom.com
everyone you know it you love it
look you ha you got a plan for your
future don't be that person living day
to day you want to be that person
you know you're out on the golf course
when you're retired
and young people look at it you go see
that guy over there that guy did it
right
you know and when you tell the story and
you're all old
and you know but still happy and the
young kid goes hey
mister how did you end up on the golf
course you can be legalzoom.com
2013. um this is the deal
you do financial planning you get
insurance but to get real peace of mind
you have to make sure your family is
legally protected
so where do you turn to get affordable
legal protection you can trust
why legalzoom.com everybody for over 12
years
they've been helping americans get
personalized wills powers of attorney
living trust real estate documents and
more legalzoom.com
legalzoom also helps start and maintain
businesses within corporations and llc
filings
trademarks and copyrights see this is
the first step you take
to start your business legalzoom.com and
then when you need the
outgoing messages you go to evoice.com
you get it
beautiful their time saving service was
developed by a team of experienced
attorneys
and legalzoom takes care of you from
start to finish legalzoom documents have
been accepted by courts and government
agencies in all 50 states
so no matter where you live in the
continental united states
even if you're up in alaska even if
you're out there in hawaii living the
life
becoming the next bruno mars they got
you covered legalzoom is not a law firm
but they can connect you to an attorney
and provide self-help services at your
specific direction
for even more savings enter burr b-u-r-r
in the referral box at checkout
um if you're a parent or an entrepreneur
don't wait any longer
call or visit legalzoom.com and protect
what's yours
and i hope you guys do it because i want
all you guys to get out there and work
for yourselves
if that's what your dream is all right
if you want to work for somebody else
that's also cool
i don't judge if you want to bang
another woman in front of your wife
because that's what she's into well god
bless you
put on a [ __ ] gators [ __ ] wear
jimmy's put on a jimmy and have a good
[ __ ] time
all right now where the hell am why is
my voice cracking was i screaming
yesterday when i was drunk
i bet i was all right
okay what are we on to the next one here
um
okay wanna oh you know what i didn't
answer his last one he said
if i go for it how would you suggest
actually finding women
who is open to the idea of being [ __ ]
in front of my wife
yeah i mean you're gonna you're gonna
have to find somebody who's uh
i would i would try and find somebody
who was
really advanced in their career
you know like a lawyer
they have to have a certain level of job
i wouldn't go on [ __ ] craigslist
and sign find somebody who works at a
baskin robbins who's down for doing
something like that that you know what i
mean
you're trying to go out and find the
cleanest person you can
and uh i would just lay it out on the
table put it on the table
and i'd have everybody get [ __ ]
tested and then i'd still wear a condom
and then i'd have at it and then
you know as far as the spaghetti-o
conversation afterwards that's on you
all right here we go here's the next one
a lot of sex ones this week what a bang
friend's sister
uh dear billy fat again uh
first i would like to say i'm a huge fan
but
the podcast influenced me changing my
life for the better great he said i'm
getting over an x
following um
i don't know he's trying to write the
boston accent i can't even read that
getting over an x following my hat and
there we go
um i want to bang my friend's sister
he even writes this in here for me oh
geez
um backstory he's been one of my better
friends for about eight years
and wasn't this amazing the power of
women
that he's been one of my better better
friends he didn't say best friend
oh wow for eight years how old is this
girl
she's 21. ugh well this is getting
creepy let's do the math
so when he first started being friends
with this guy his sister was 13 years
old
dude come on
that's [ __ ] creepy so at what point
did you start looking at her like hey
those titties are starting to come in
there
ah jesus ah i'm gonna have to shower
after this one but you know what
i understand i understand what happens
uh
for the better part of eight years and
we went to high school and college
together party got in trouble and all
that other guy stuff
and straight he's going to put it right
on the table he goes i want to bang her
sister
i'm going to bang her sister he goes i
have known her since she was young
and i am now 25 and she's 21 okay so
when she was 13
you were 17. all right and she's now a
21 year old
lady oh this is filthy sir
this is filthy did she still have braces
the first time you saw her
anyways smoking hot she's developed like
she was welker in the patriots offense
this guy is a creep
oh this guy is a creep i love you i love
you to death sir
he goes i ended up getting a number from
the one time we hung out with their
brother and several others
so you're hanging out with his brother
and on the side you're suddenly hitting
on her
dude you don't need me listen you're
going to bang this girl
the end of this email should be you just
asking should i do
it or should i not but as far as
anything else
if you're getting the [ __ ] number
of one of your better friend's sister
while he's two feet away
you know waiting for his maybe it's his
chance to shoot pool
you know you go shoot some stick and you
can get the number during that time
you don't need my help in that
department obviously
all right so anyways the one time we
hung out okay and with several others
and she used my phone to take pictures
and texted herself the pictures
oh yeah oh jesus this is a layup right
here
he goes i have not contacted her since
because i'm not sure what to do
should i bang my friend's sister p.s
this friend has previously banged one of
my other friends sisters
and has never told him uh oh the two
wrongs make a right for me
to bang my friend's sister he wrote it
in capital letters
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
all right um
wow there's a lot of there's a little
[ __ ] twist there in the end
so you're gonna use your [ __ ] dick as
some sort of karmic
like balance in the sexual universe
karmically he does deserve this but not
by you
the [ __ ] dude whose sister got banged
he should go and [ __ ] bang his sister
and here's another thing too if this
girl is as hot
as you say she is you are running the
risk that she's just a [ __ ]
narcissistic like dick tease
and she's taking phones with your camera
with your cell phone camera
just because that's just what she
[ __ ] does just takes oh my god look
how hot i am ah look at this
angle look at me doing this ooh i'm
making the duck face right
um oh man
i don't know what to tell you here sir
you could do the age-old rub one out rub
one out
and then in the zen afterwards think
about it if you still want to do it
then i'd say check your shoot and
[ __ ]
jump out the back of the plane um
you know what dude this is on you
because i don't you said you haven't
said much about the guy
you seem to have sort of like this is a
guy that you've hung with but you don't
seem
to be saying that you guys have a real
strong friendship and he's kind of a
dirt bag and bang one of your friends
you know what [ __ ] her
do it do it
every once in a while i say go and do
the dumb thing you're young enough
by all means wear a [ __ ] condom
uh it's just gonna be so [ __ ] sneaky
this is nothing too if all you want to
do is bang her if you have no feelings
for it you
are you are risking this [ __ ]
relationship
and if you know what's going to be
hilarious is when he comes running up to
your house and you know it's going to be
raining out because whenever you find
out your friend
[ __ ] your sister and you have to go
beat the [ __ ] out of him it's always
raining out
god helps you out so your buddy who
[ __ ] your sister also doesn't see the
tears in your eyes because it's pouring
down rating
and you bang on that screen door right
bang on that [ __ ] thingy
you [ __ ] my sister get out of the front
lawn you guys roll around the mud
punching each other
now you got to understand that like what
is your out gonna be there
yeah well you [ __ ] so and so sister so
it's even
does he know that you know that he
[ __ ] the other person's sister
this is like an episode of dallas
i say you do let me know this is the
last question i have
that kid you've known for eight years
what is his martial art background
what if his uh when he gets into fights
in bars does he have a tendency to bite
somebody's ear off
is he a maniac can you beat this guy
if he jumps you in your own driveway you
know
you know what i don't know why
because i usually give good advice i'm
telling you right now this is a dumb
thing to do but i'm telling you to go
out and go do it
go on go do it [ __ ] him he banged your
father buddy sister go ahead
make it all right with your dick make
the world right again
with your dick please give me a
follow-up email i wanna know how it goes
down all right
but this is the thing you gotta let her
jump in the boat all right
make it be her [ __ ] idea this is the
deal
the whole time you're doing speak you
know i don't know about this but
you know i feel guilty because just let
it be no it's okay
let her [ __ ] die bomb down on your
dick and then you're all right right
i'm gonna tell you all of that advice
came with the giant [ __ ] asterisk
beyond that i'm a [ __ ] and i'm not a
therapist but i'm i'm telling you
to step into the quicksand because i
think that you have the ability to make
it to the other side
i believe in you sir good luck
and god bless um dilemma what would you
do for a billion dollars
that you wouldn't do for a million
um not a lot i'm not motivated by money
to be honest with you what would i do
for a billion dollars
that i wouldn't do for a million all
right for a million dollars
now you know what i'm gonna be honest if
i wouldn't do it for a million then i
wouldn't do it for a billion
i could live off a million
is that tax-free by the way free and
clear
prenup and all that [ __ ] that's my
million
let's see what would i do for a million
dollars would i eat dog [ __ ]
no i wouldn't humiliate myself
you know i i i'm not motivated my
motivated by money
you know what if i was still working in
a warehouse unloading trucks
that would be a good time to ask me that
question
all right but i make enough money
to pay my mortgage and get these banker
cuts [ __ ] off my back as soon as i can
uh you know what i'm a happy guy
keep your money you can't buy this
red-headed [ __ ]
i'm sorry i know that you wanted a
funnier answer than that but i
i don't have it i don't give a [ __ ]
once i once it's not worth the trouble
i've never understood those game shows
that one rogan hosted where people were
eating yak balls
it's like for what why you know have a
shred of [ __ ] self-esteem
what's wrong with you you never do
something for the money
you know unless i look i'll do a bad
stand-up gig
for the money because i'm trying to pay
down the house i'll do that
i'll i mean i would do that but nobody's
gonna give me a million dollars to do
stand-up
ah jesus we were doing so well let me
see if i can make this one funny
girlfriends passed a
billy boy i have i have i'm having
problems i'm having problems reading
this sir i'm having problems dealing
with all the guys my girlfriend has
[ __ ] before me
she's 17 and a senior in high school and
she's been with four to five guys
all the way and blown more
now why are you saying four to five you
know
if you've only [ __ ] four or five
people she ought to be able to remember
all of them
she said my first girlfriend i'm 18.
be easy there buddy go easy is 17
considered underage
because you get busted for statutory
rape
uh make sure she's legal he goes she's
my first
girlfriend i'm 18 but i wasn't a virgin
because
before because my neighbor forced me
to have sex with her when i was five
what
sex with what
your little ding dong
what was she doing
dude that's [ __ ] creepy i didn't even
know that
anyways she lost her virginity in a
one-night stand when she was 14
it just kills me every day that my
virginity was stolen from me
and she just gives hers away it doesn't
help that she still goes to the same
school
as the guy and while they don't really
talk she [ __ ] him again last summer
a couple of months before we started
dating i feel like she's just
let people use her and it really
disgusts me
i don't even know if i love her or if i
even like her very much
am i overreacting about her past or not
no dude what you're doing is you're
tapping into how you feel about this
girl
and what you're looking for in a woman
and this girl isn't it okay
it's you know hopefully what whatever
happened to you didn't happen to her
but um
what would you do sir is you're fighting
your self-esteem
or discovering it all right listen to
that voice
okay this isn't the kind of woman that
you're looking to be with so
i would break up with her all right and
then get with the girl
that hasn't [ __ ] four to five guys
that you're gonna pass on your way to
math class
all right that's the deal
all right you sound like you've gone
through some [ __ ] i'd probably go to
therapy over that one there
you know whatever the [ __ ] happened to
you and
uh but what's great is you come out of
this that you you
are still tapped in what you're looking
for in a girlfriend you want you want
you know
a great girl deserves a great guy and
you sound like you're a great guy
so go out there and get a great girl
that's what you should do
all right and be healthy human beings
with one another
okay don't let what the [ __ ] happened to
you when you're five go down some dark
sexual road
that you pick these damaged girls that
you relate to both of you probably need
to go to therapy work some [ __ ] out
all right but she didn't write me you
did so i'm telling you to do that
and um yeah get yourself
yeah the [ __ ] is with my voice
get a girl that you're proud to be with
that you want to bring home to your
parents
all right that's the one there you go
all right and that's it everybody that's
the podcast for this week i just got a
couple of things i got some
announcements as far
as where i'm gonna be uh this is
actually a huge gig in my life
um i've always wanted to work las vegas
and i did it on the way up
but the way vegas works is either uh
you know you're headlining a great room
or you're working some dump and i was
always in some dump and it was a
depressing place to be because when you
work in a dump
in las vegas you know basically the
uh you know you just see these gamblers
that [ __ ] they don't have any money
and it's just it's it's [ __ ] horrific
so i was never able to
headline any place nice when i was out
there
except when i i toured with uh jimmy
norton jim brewer and uh
david tells so this is the first time
i'm actually gonna go get to go out
there
and headline a major casino i'm gonna be
at the mirage casino
may 17 and may 18th in las vegas nevada
i'm obviously beyond honored to be out
there and um
i love it if you guys came out showed up
took a trip to vegas or whatever i
believe there's still a few tickets left
and um and later on in the month i'm
going to do a nice east coast
run count basie theater in red bank new
jersey may 29th
may 30th i'm going to be at the i hope i
say this right
mayerhof symphony hall in baltimore
maryland
may 31st the state theater center for
the arts in eastern pennsylvania and on
june 1st i have two shows
at the borgata casino and spa
in atlantic city new jersey so uh
please come out there i believe on that
trip that new jersey swing
is gonna be the one and only the teen
idol sensation
joe derosa who has a half hour comedy
central special debuting i believe this
weekend
on comedy central please email uh
tweet joe derosa facebook him find out
when his half hour special is
please watch your special because how
comedy central works is
is if the ratings are beyond a certain
point they're gonna keep showing it
and uh joe's one of the great guys both
on and off business it would be really
great if you guys would uh
if you check out his special and with
that
we are down to the final announcement
that i have on this if you guys would
like to donate to the podcast
go to amazon go to billboard.com
on the uh click on the podcast page
if you want to buy something on amazon
click on the amazon banner
and